while the checkers deal may well have
United the cabinet but some Euroskeptic
Tory MPs have already raised a number of
concerns so much so that it's reported
some may be considering trying to
trigger a leadership contest
sir bill Cash's campaign long and hard
for brexit and he joins me now very good
to see you what do you make of it I'm
presuming not much well first of all we
got the withdrawal act through repealing
the 1972 act is the crown of all that is
the most important thing if you repeal
the 72 act you get out of the rules and
obligations you also get out of the
court of justice the problem is that
this statement these three pages
followed by the white paper which of
course we haven't seen yes indeed and
all the curfuffle and shenanigans that
we witnessed over the last 24 hours
actually raises enormous number of very
very serious questions specifically well
specifically the question is to what
extent are we going to be bound by EU
rules I mean that is to summarize this I
mean if you leave you leave and that is
what the question set asked for and that
is what the answer they got so the
question is are we actually going to
leave or are we going to be bound in to
some form of legal framework as I said
to the Prime Minister on Monday that
this last week or which will amount to
some kind of legal reentry of some
description now until we see the white
paper we can't not ducking the question
at all what I am saying on the basis of
what I've seen so far and the
discussions that have emerged in the
commentaries I think people have every
reason to be concerned yeah it indeed it
in the terms that it's described I'm in
a common rule book I mean it sounds like
you've got a copy of you know the rules
of Association but you're all in your
bag well it's the EU colour is the EU
common rule book as well by all accounts
and the question is how and to what
extent would we actually be able to make
our own decisions on our own terms one
of the biggest mistakes that was made in
my opinion from the beginning was
accepting the EU guidelines as being the
basis on which we would negotiate so
we've effectively put ourselves in the
position where we are more supplicating
than actually saying we're leaving and
we have absolutely equal rights as my
European scrutiny committee report said
a short time ago
we have an absolutely equal right with
the other member states because we're
leaving under article 50 we've heard
from Michael Gove elsewhere this morning
and indeed in the statement that we
would retain the ability to say no if
there was a rule change that we didn't
like we could say no but presumably
there would be consequences that's
looked from that well it's not only that
there would be consequences that flow
from it because the Prime Minister's
made that clear and she made it clear in
a previous speech as well as matter of
fact but the real point is this that
when you're dealing with the manner in
which the laws are made in the Council
of Ministers if we're tied in to those
arrangements but we're not actually at
the table and we don't have a judge in
the European Court then what happen is
that the decisions were taken by the 27
in creating the new rules and then the
question will arise to what extent are
we actually going to be bound by them I
think there's a complete lack of clarity
there and that's one of the things that
this white paper has really got to sort
out and by the way a white paper is what
it says it's a beginning of a statement
of policy there's going to be a huge
amount of argument and a great deal of
determination to get these things clear
I mean there's no way around this though
according to the statement from checkers
or a couple of days ago I mean we would
be a rule taker and not a real mang I I
believe that is the case so what follows
from that I mean that does the brexit
that you have wanted to see well what
I'm saying is that we have a white paper
and there's going to be an enormous
amount of argument and discussion about
what these words mean so as Carol said
words mean what you choose them to me
and the question is who is to be master
that is all and quite frankly the master
cannot be the EU in terms of freedom of
movement do you see this as coming to an
end from what you've heard thus far I
mean in the the statement you know point
H end free movement giving the UK back
control over how many people enter the
country point I include a mobility
framework so that u eq UK and EU
citizens can continue to travel and work
in other countries is very vague I mean
nobody actually knows what a very vague
it's not very well it says that we're
going to take back control of our
borders and at the same time allow EU
citizens to come with work here but as
the oilers a it's contradictory I think
that's not the way of putting it but the
bottom line is that she said yesterday
unequivocally the freedom of movement
would end and one
where you have to as I get as I said
there last week in Parliament well if
you repeal seventy-two acts you actually
achieve three things first of all you
get out of the customs union you regain
your sovereignty and at the same time
you also get out of the single market
and you reject the European Court of
Justice the question is how and to what
extent will this white paper actually
square that particular circle because
the reality is it's clear and it's the
law of the land doesn't the agreement on
goods look to you awfully like you know
a smaller trim down single market
customs union well it looks like very
much like the new customs partnership
which we went through a few weeks ago
and that was rejected by a meeting of
the sub cabinets of the cabinet and so
that's another area which raises a
enormous number of questions because the
most important thing is that we have to
be able to trade independently
throughout the world to be able to gain
the maximum benefits and 59 percent of
all the existing arrangements within the
EU in terms of our trading relationship
and our trading relations has now
dropped to fifty nine fifty four fifty
nine to forty two percent but ninety
percent and this is a key point of all
future growth in the world and we
outside the EU that is the prize and
that's what we have to do so we have to
have an independent trade policy and
anything that gets in that way is going
to be a very very serious disadvantage
and may be very very bad for the UK it's
true somebody's position today any more
or less secure as a result of what's
emerged from checkers well have you
written a letter I have not no I I'm
certainly not saying anything of the
kind what I am saying is that this is a
white paper it was an enormous triumph
or victory against all the massive
arrays of the House of Lords and the
remain as the ramona's the reverses all
the rest of it rewrites the lot they all
did everything to stop that going
through in a way in which we wanted it
to go through but it did go through we
got the act and the bottom line is that
that gives us the sovereignty of the
United Kingdom Parliament back but now
we're into the business of how we deal
with this part of the process which is
the white paper and the other thing is
all the EU even remotely going to accept
all this that's a that's a really big
question indeed but my point is this so
for all the triumphalism about the fact
that actually you know our Prime
Minister got her cabinet to agree to
something emerging from checkers it
strikes me that given the fact on the
Sunday papers once again we're hearing
talk of people at writing letters to the
chairman of the 1922 it doesn't look
like she's any safer
well it certainly raises a lot of
pressure marks on that account as well
and by the way if people were to decide
to put in those letters you need 48 and
as a matter of fact that nobody can stop
them and once the decision has been
taken by those people the chairman of
the 1922 committee has to implement the
process but the key question is that
there are a lot of questions in here
there is a lot of unhappiness there is a
great deal of concern that we're saying
that we leave it this way right it's not
just to be or not to be it's to leave or
not to leave the question is how do you
leave and is this going to be a proper
brexit and there will be a massive
discussion about all this it's a white
paper and that provides us with the
means to do it and we're gonna do a
thorough analysis of it and we'll come
up with our own analysis and we'll put
it to the cabinet and to the British
people I'll bet you will thank you